Love is never enough
anyone with a brain and a pulse can fall in love with someone
but that is never gonna sustain a relationship
What will is connection
safety, trust and communication
You can love someone until you're blue in the face
but that's not gonna be enough
The better question to ask is
Does your partner feel valued and respected?
Do they feel like a priority in your life,
Do you appreciate each other?
Can you take accountability when you mess up?
Can you repair conflicts and are you someone that they can be vulnerable around?
Do you listen when they tell you what they need to feel valued?
“HOW” you love each other is the biggest difference.